standing with taiwan in defiance of
china u.s house speaker nancy pelosi has
ended her controversial visit to the
self-ruled island it's triggered an
angry response from beijing but how will
taipei and washington deal with the
fallout this is inside story
[Music]
hello welcome to the program i'm kim
vanell nancy pelosi has become the most
senior u.s politician to visit taiwan in
25 years
the u.s house speaker spent less than a
day on the self-ruled island but china
which claims taiwan as part of its
territory called the trip a direct
challenge to its sovereignty beijing had
issued threats and warnings before
pelosi even touched down but america's
third most powerful politician was
undeterred saying washington was
committed to preserving taiwan's
democracy
china is responding with live-fire
military drills and an import ban on
taiwanese products we'll bring in our
guests in a moment but first this report
from mohammed jamjum
for u.s house speaker nancy pelosi a
high-profile trip to taiwan
fraught with both complications and
contradictions
america's third most powerful politician
repeating washington's commitment to
protect democracy on the self-governed
island while also respecting beijing's
so-called one china policy
today the world faces a choice between
democracy and autocracy
america's determination to preserve
democracy here in taiwan and around the
world
remains ironclad taiwanese president xi
jinguin who gave pelosi one of the
highest civilian honors promised to
defend the island from beijing's threats
aggression against democratic taiwan
would have a tremendous impact on the
security of the entire indo-pacific
facing deliberately heightened military
threats taiwan will not back down we
will firmly uphold our nation's
sovereignty and continue to hold the
line of defence for democracy
china which considers taiwan a part of
its territory has said it wants a
peaceful reunification and views
pelosi's visit as a direct provocation
taiwan's saying wen and her ilk are
clinging to the us and turning their
backs on national justice these
behaviors that go against the trend of
times will not change the international
consensus of one china and will not
change the historic trend that taiwan
will inevitably return to the motherland
those who play with fire will not come
to a good end and those who offend china
will be punished
even during pelosi's visit china's
reaction was fast and furious suspending
imports and exports of several goods to
and from taiwan
conducting joint air and sea live
ammunition drills near taiwan and
summoning the u.s ambassador in beijing
pelosi's trip has come to an end but
with chinese american relations at such
a low point it's not clear yet what the
long-term repercussions of this visit
will be
for inside story
well let's look more closely at the u.s
relationship with taiwan washington does
not have formal diplomatic ties with the
island but maintains what it calls a
policy of strategic ambiguity it
recognises the chinese government in
beijing but not china's territorial
claim to taiwan
the u.s does supply weapons to taipei
under its 1979 taiwan relations act
the island is a major economic and
technology partner to the u.s it
supplies more than half of the world's
semiconductors
china sees taiwan as a breakaway
province that will eventually be united
and hasn't ruled out using force
let's bring in our guests in taipei
vincent chao former director of the
political division at the taipei
economic and cultural representative
office in the u.s and a former chief of
staff to both the taiwan national
security council and foreign minister in
miami june toefl dreyer a professor of
political science at the university of
miami and editor of the book taiwan in
the area of citing when
changes and challenges and in beijing
henry hui wang
founder and president of the center for
china and globalization and director of
the chinese people's institute of
foreign affairs a very warm welcome to
you all
i'd like to start with you henry hui
wang in beijing with your thoughts on
nancy pelosi's visit and the reaction
that we've seen so far to that visit
well i think this is a really uh a very
uh
uh bad move actually on on the part of
uh nancy pelosi because
she
came at uh you know
you know the bilateral relation between
china u.s already at the lowest point
also the the war is facing pandemic and
facing uh ukraine russian crisis and
energy crisis and many other crisis as
well so
uh we just had the presidential and
president biden talking last week and we
also had the five
uh high level uh dialogue between senior
officials between china us in the last
two months
so we we we don't want to see this
happen actually
uh uh for her nancy pelosi personal
gains because she she has been branded
has been really uh make her name uh uh
make her
uh you know know that anti-china and uh
and also really uh not not in the uh you
know in good relations uh with with
development of china-u.s relations so
she's uh she's really i think arthur is
a political
uh motivation and for the domestic
politics i think that she's really uh
you know went to taiwan and made this
unprecedented move
so i think it's going to damage the
uh not only the u.s china region but
also bring the series uh
crisis to the cross street uh of taiwan
and so this is going to be really
breaking a lot of uh
status quo and i think there's going to
be a lot of consequences in the
in the future that uh that really could
we see the deterioration of these
relations okay i just want to pause you
there and and cross over to taipei
vincent ciao what do you make of nancy
pelosi's uh reception in taiwan what
does her visit mean for taiwan well just
to start um henry's point about um
anti-china i think what he's really
trying to say is she's been
pro-democracy
basically her whole life if anything i
think she's pro-china democracy and she
was in tian men
she showed support for democracy both in
china and in taiwan in the past and i
think what it comes down to is this
pelosi has a great track record when it
comes to supporting human rights and
democracy around the world and her
coming here to taiwan is second nature
to death and when we look at it there's
no breaking of the status quo um newt
gingrich as speaker had come here in
1997. the chinese did not dispatch
fighter jets they did not did not
announce live fire exercises did not
engage in economic sanctions and so it
becomes a bit disingenuous to say
that hey i mean
china's not changed uh china has changed
this is clearly within president this
has been done before the reaction this
time is far above and beyond what we saw
the last time around and so clearly um
something within the ccp has changed and
it's difficult to imagine a scenario
where countries around the region and
the us are not going to respond to that
um june toefl drea is there anything
that you would add to that
yes i i
believe that the speaker from beijing
uh earth when he said that this is
upsetting status quo
china has been upsetting the status quo
and the taiwan strait for quite some
time now
with a lot of provocative actions and
talks about timetables for unification
which they persisted calling
reunification
even though taiwan has never been part
of the people's republic of china and i
was appalled at the
the effort to rewrite history here hua
chunying who is the spokeswoman for the
chinese foreign ministry saying that
taiwan has always been a province of
china this is simply not true it was
declared a province in the qing dynasty
for less than 10 years less than 10
years
when
japan took it over and made it a colony
of japan
and you know lying about the facts
um is not going to help soothe the
situation
and so
i think pelosi's visit was designed as
vincent was saying uh do as a show of
support beca against china's trying to
change the status quo
what just before we move on um mr what
why does taiwan matter so much to nancy
pelosi and and to the us
it matters for a number of reasons uh
one of the reasons nancy pelosi
gave is that she has always been a
strong supporter of democracy around the
world as has the united states in
general
which
immediately puts it against china which
is defending authoritarianism but a
second reason is strategic
taiwan is strategically extremely
important
um
because it is the
part of the first island chain of
defense against aggression by the
people's liberation army
and
it is uh
chinese military strategists have
referred to taiwan
as the
a buckle in the chain
that keeps the people's liberation army
bottled up
behind
the first island chain
and breaking taking over taiwan
would mean getting access to a very
important port cauchun
and also
entryway and they have specifically said
an entryway to the blue pacific and guam
and guam is a u.s territory
and of course
halfway toward hawaii
so that bothers american strategic
planners of course um i'd like to go
back to henry huyawang in beijing china
obviously views this visit as a
violation what are the chances that you
think china would go beyond um live fire
drills and actually take military action
in taiwan
well i think this is uh really uh
really a breaking the
uh the pattern and the norm in the last
you know four or five decades actually
break the status quo because in the in
the 1979 you know the john's complicated
established by china u.s the john
communication stipulates you know of
course uh
u.s can maintain culture and commercial
ties with taiwan but don't officialize
that's a very clear statement there
that's the prerequisite that you know
established diplomatic ties with u.s
between u.s and china and also for 181
countries around the world the china
established diplomatic advisories but
this is not establishing diplomatic ties
this is just a visit from the house
speaker
well this is the door of his contact
she's the third highest banking official
in the united states she's official
absolutely she's the official that's the
official visit that's that's uh that's a
fact i mean also uh taiwan is a part of
china for
for the long history it's it's always a
part of china it's first time for me to
hear that thailand's not part of china
that's that's really nonsense so so i
think that uh you know she really uh
break that pattern and uh
that's why i mean chinese always uh
responds i mean china didn't provoke
this this is provoked by nazi pelosi and
also military exercise you mentioned
about around the taiwan uh uh would be
really a response uh merely a response
but i have to you know that's uh there's
anti-succession law there's there's a uh
there's a independence that uh you know
cabin authority is trying to seek and
then and then of course you guys are
playing this thailand car it's really uh
escalating the the situation there sure
i just want to come back to my initial
question do you think that china would
actually take military action in taiwan
well i think that china's already you
know i mean uh you know there's there's
a flight uh over uh uh middle uh of the
street uh already last night and also
from the from the third or seven they're
going to be many directors around taiwan
that's already planned and announced
already so so the absolute there's a
responses as the action
is taken there that that's very very
obvious so so that is also uh
set a record there as well in responding
to this
visited by nazi plus
um vincent ciao and taipei
are everyday taiwanese people uh
concerned about the rationing up of
tensions concerned about these live fire
drills that are going to be happening
i think what's unfortunate is that um
provocations and military intimidation
and coercion to a certain degree have
become part and parcel of everyday life
here in taipei and we've really seen
um a ramping up of tensions from the drc
military jets flying across our air
defense identification zone uh economic
course of actions including most
recently the banning of a few uh food
products and so forth and so it's become
really just
a part of routine life and and you know
that has its pitfalls on its own but
it's also an unfortunate consequence of
the relationship or the lack of one we
see today but i i do have to emphasize
one point if we take this idea of china
meaning the people's republic of china
taiwan has never been part of the prc
and this is a historical fact there's no
there's never been a people's liberation
army soldier here in taiwan um the pure
season every occupied taiwan has never
set foot on taiwan and so it becomes
very disingenuous to say that um
thailand has become it had his part of
china for a very very long time and so
that's partially what i want to respond
to but secondly on the taiwan relations
act and and three communities and all of
that
nowhere within any of these documents
doesn't mention that um no speaker
can visit taiwan but no members of the
legislative branch can visit taiwan and
or no members of the executive branch
for that matter this is just not part of
what's written literature within the
three communicated order how relations
act or the six assurances for that
matter and so we have to be very
clear-eyed because we don't want to
stumble into the next crisis based on
hearsay and we don't want to stumble
into next crisis based on word of mouth
so we have to be very clear what's in
the tax and what's keeping with the
status quo and when we have a visit by
speaker of the house that has clearly
taken place 25 years ago
it becomes very very difficult for us in
2022
to say that this is completely against
the status quo it's just not true okay i
want to talk about u.s policy toward
taiwan but
do we just want to take a moment because
president joe biden caused controversy
back in may when he publicly stated that
the u.s would defend taiwan if beijing
were to attack you didn't want to get
involved in the ukraine conflict
militarily for obvious reasons are you
willing to get involved militarily to
defend taiwan if it comes to that yes
you are
that's the commitment we made
the commitment we may we are not look
here's the situation
we agree with the one china policy we've
signed on to it and all the attendant
agreements made from there
but the idea that
that it can be taken by force
just taken by force is just not it's
just not appropriate it'll dislocate the
entire region
and be another action similar to what
happened in
in ukraine now the white house quickly
uh insisted that washington's policy had
not in fact changed uh june toefl drea
has the biden administration been
confused about its policy was that just
a gaffe on
the part of president biden
well it may well have been a gaffe but
in fact what china has been doing
is insisting on its definition of a one
china policy
which is that there is but one china and
its capital is in beijing and taiwan is
a part of that that is not what the
united states signed on to the shanghai
communique said very clearly that the
united states acknowledges that uh
that this is the chinese
view
it did not say it agreed with china
right
and so china has been trying to
shift what the united states meant in
the shanghai communique
it has in fact been trying to shift the
status quo
for many years
and there is always going to be pushback
the united states public opinion is
strongly supportive of taiwan's ability
to determine its own future
many of your top officials in taiwan
were educated within in the united
states
and uh it is it is very important to us
not to let a a democracy which has been
a good friend of the united states
succumb to the treatment that beijing
has meted out in xinjiang and in hong
kong okay uh i'd like to cross over to
you henry wang is there uh do you have
any response to that what you just heard
there
well i think that uh you know in the
communique they were saying the the
people across the taiwan street all
recognize that they are chinese i mean
there is one china i mean uh also we
have these 92 consensus uh there there
was even a meeting
between president xi and the former
president mahindra you know the taiwan
leaders then so uh
you know definitely a little before the
uh before the chinese took over millions
of mainland chinese tour the taiwan and
also you know the the people in both
places share the same culture same
language same food and same heritage so
so i think it's really it's like china
uh you know you have a different
interpretation problem okay
you know
we don't want to get stuck on the
sticking point um of of history because
obviously that we have we have
conflicting views here
i i want to get into the analysis of
this before i move on from you henry
wang
is this do you think just a is this a
bilateral spat between the us and china
or what are the global implications of
this do you think
well it has tremendous impact on the
global you know china is the uh
stabilizer of the global economy china
contributed over one third of the global
gdp growth china actually
is the largest trading nation with 130
countries and china you know even with
the trade war going on china export to
the us is those import experts has
increased in the last several years so
so you know is is a stabilizer we don't
want to you know the war now is actually
uh we are experiencing the ukraine
russian crisis uh and and also that uh
we have uh these pandemics doing a lot
going on and uh you know the world need
both u.s and china they have more
responsibility to see the world really
going in the right direction so we don't
want to really be uh
really plagued about this
domestic politics that china become a
scapegoat and also we see that in the
five high-level talks and meetings
between presidential and president biden
they all said one china policy they
don't want to have a cold war they don't
want to contain china okay but let's do
the
do the deeds not not just the words you
know that's really the problem you know
china cairo has been played as a
political car against china which is
very unfortunate uh vincent ciao and
taipei um as we said earlier uh china
has responded with an import ban on
taiwanese products is taiwan able to
withstand the economic price that it's
now being forced to pay well it's a it's
a it's a far-reaching relationship the
economic and trade relationship that we
have with china and it's it's
unfortunate fact that it's true that a
majority of trade does go through china
and that um china is a major center for
taiwanese businesses and so that's an
important part of town's economy and so
it's it's a bit disappointing when um
both china and taiwan are members of the
wto when we see arbitrary trade rules
enforced on felonies products without
due process when we see uh trade being
really played as a
um an economic card against um this
relationship and and frankly that's
painful for a lot of counties businesses
and it's also something we don't hope to
see but you know we do have to put it in
this context i mean taiwan is a
industrial powerhouse we're a high-tech
society and you know um obviously trade
on agricultural is important and
agricultural provides a lot of jobs here
in taiwan but it's it's it's one aspect
of a many much multi-faceted
relationship and let me end on this note
um this trade dispute with china has
really highlighted the need of why
trips like pelosi's are so important
because taiwan does need economically
diverse funds and as a free market
capitalist society we need to provide
incentives preferably through free trade
agreements and so this is something that
we're looking very keenly at and we do
hope that we can make progress on a free
trade agreement with the u.s in the
future
june toyfield dream we are coming to the
end of the program but i want to ask you
cyanwing has posited herself as a
defender of taiwan's
uh integrity what kind of position are
they in now i think that this can only
enhance her popularity
now she is term limited she's in her
second term as president
um but
i
predict with some certainty that her
popularity ratings which were already
pretty good because as you know taiwan
was a vegan for the world countries uh
in terms of dealing with covet outbreak
and so her popularity ratings were
already very high they are going to be
higher as a result of this visit
do you think there is international
concern um
june that
china u.s tensions over taiwan may
divert attention from ukraine
internationally uh that's a very
interesting question because initially
it was brooded about that one of the
reasons xi jinping was being so
aggressive toward taiwan which by the
way prompted nancy pelosi's visit
uh is that uh
it was losing uh and
it was it was dispirited by what was
happening in ukraine and it thought that
the united states would be so distracted
by what was happening in ukraine that it
wouldn't do anything to counteract the
increasing chinese aggression against
taiwan and as this visit shows that view
was mistaken
all right uh i think that is about all
we have time for there's obviously so
much we could more we could talk about
but for time we will have to leave it
there uh a big thank you to all of our
guests vincent ciao june toefl drea and
henry hui wang and thank you two for
watching you can see the program again
anytime by visiting our website al
jazeera.com
and for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story
you can also join the conversation over
on twitter we are at aj inside story or
you can get me at kimvanelle from me kim
and the whole team here in doha bye for
now